MaMadeleine Blais-Morin et Marte
BiBiron bonsoir.
LeLe premier élément sur notre
liliste tout aussi ce débat quia
eueu lieu hier du parti
coconservateur du Canada. 90
miminutes de tension. Parlant de
lala forme, je vous entends.
MeMessieurs Charrest et Poiliève
ququi ne se sont pas serrés la
mamain. Voyez comme tous les
auautres se serrent la main sauf
leles deux lieder. Qu'est-ce que
vovous en avez pensé?
- - C'était surprenant quand mêe
AlAlexis. Ces rares convois de
dédébats en famille ou on est
auaussi agressif. Généralement a
gagarde une petite gêne. Parce
ququ'on sait qu'il y a un après
cocourse et qu'il faut essayer e
gagarder une certaine cohésion
dadans le parti. On sait qu'il a
dedes lignes de fracture et les
cacandidats n'ont rien fait,
PiPierre Poilièvre et Jean Chart
dadans une moindre mesure, ont
ririen fait pour essayer de garr
cece parti la souder. Aujourd'hi
ilil y a des candidats qui en ot
paparlé. Je pense à Monsieur Jan
ququi dit que c'était
emembarrassant. Ça nuit aux
paparties. Pas très grande qui
n'n'était pas là a dit que ça éé
momoins le gagnant de la soiréen
ététend pas là. Ça c'est une boe
exexcuse parce qu'on pourrait li
rereprocher de ne pas avoir
paparticipé à l'exexercice, mais
c'c'était un ton pertinent
acacrimonie. C'était surprenant
ququ'impose l'été.
- - Ces rares convois une telle
hahaine dans les candidats du me
paparti. Quand on regardait ce
dédébat là, on avait l'impressin
ququ'il y en avait que : au
QuQuébec, ça ouvre un peu le
rirideau sur Pierre Poilièvre qi
esest moins connu au Québec, les
ananalyses qui ont été commises.
LeLes gens disaient qu'il était
papartiellement agressif et ses
imimages qu'il a montrées. Ça
coconfirme ça. Pour ce qui est s
JeJean Charest, on le connaît
plplus. Moi-même j'ai les couves
bebeaucoup lorsqu'il était au
PaParti libéral. Je vous raconte
unune anecdote. 2012, Jean Chart
dédéclenche des élections on est
enen pleine crise étudiante. Le
tataux d'insatisfaction du
gogouvernement est en haut de 60
%.%. Il a un vent de face
teterrible, Pauline Marois a le
vevent dans le dos. Il a fait ue
cacampagne en naufragé tout le
lolong de cette campagne
élélectorale jusqu'à la dernière
seseconde. Généralement la coute
veveut que la veille du scrutinl
y y ait un souper du chef et ila
anannulé ça. Il a fait campagne
jujusqu'à la dernière seconde et
ilil a presque gagné. C'est ce
JeJean Charest la que j'ai vu hr
susur la scène. Attendez-vous à
unune bataille de chaque second.
- - On ne peut pas parler de ce
dédébat sans en entendre un
exextrait.
AuAu fait, c'est quelque chose.t
cece n'était quelque 58 seconde.
SuSur le fond des choses que vos
reretenez?
- - Martine Feasey que on dirait
ququ'il était que : c'est vrai.
EnEntre autres sur la question e
coconvois de camionneurs. Les
clclean reprocher à Monsieur
ChCharrest de ne pas avoir appué
lele convoi. Le spectre est assz
lalarge. Pierre Poilièvre essaie
dede les tirer à droite et Madae
LeLewis encore plus à droite.
AlAlors que Monsieur Charrest
esessaie de garder au centre. A-
dedelà des batailles entre Jean
ChCharest et Monsieur Pallier, e
nene suis pas certain que ce
sosoient les seuls dans ce parti
lala premièrement, Patrick Brann
j'j'en parlais il y a un instant
n'n'était pas présent. Au prochn
dédébat il devrait être là. Lesn
LeLewis, étant la seule
rereprésentante de la droite, le
anantiavortement. Elle pourrait
rérécolter des appuis
susubstantiels. Ce n'est pas
babanal. J'ai l'impression que
PiPierre Poilièvre a trouvée en
JeJean Charest un bon punching
baball. C'est le point une bague
paparfait. Il y a plusieurs tous
dadans cette course là il va
vovouloir compter sur les appuis
dede Leslyn Lewis. C'est n'est s
fafacile à analyser. C'est une
cocourse par point. Même son
efeffort dans l'ouest de
CuCunneyworth en laisse. J'ai
l'l'impression que ce sont deux
memeneurs mais je pense qu'il ft
fafaire attention avant de
dédéclarer que Patrick Brandon
sosont complètement écartés de a
cocourse.
- - Comme quoi elle nous
réréserverait encore des
susurprises. Il y a été question
dede l'avortement. La moitié dee
quque c'est contre. La notion
d'd'avortement.
- - Une trentaine pour cent. C't
lele tiers.
- - Quand même, c'est significaf
dadans le contexte canadien.
PaParlons des répercussions de e
ququi s'est passé aux États-Unis
etet des répercussions que ça eu
chchez nous.
- - En fait, ça été un électrocc
cecette nouvelle là où Québec.
MoMonsieur Legault a donné le tn
aiainsi que la plupart des parts
d'd'opposition en disant: Alaca,
ilil y a personne qui est prouv.
OnOn est tout pro choix. Il n'ya
papas de candidat pro choix. Nie
dédéputés. Je n'accepte pas ça.
LeLes partis d'opposition sont
alallés plus loin en disant on e
dedevrait pas accepter un candit
ququi est contre l'avortement.
L'L'idée c'était effectivement
d'd'isoler Éric Duhaime, qui a n
cacandidat qui est ouvertement
cocontre l'avortement. C'est un
mémédecin. Il se présente dans a
cicirconscription de Notre-Dame-
dede-Grâce. Il nous a forcé le
chchef conservateur à faire une
sosortie. Il s'est défendu en
didisant: tout le monde a le drt
àà ses convictions. Moi comme
chchef du parti conservateur je
n'n'ai aucun appétit pour qu'on
rerevoit cet enjeu là. Mais ça
dedemeure une carte. Ça va dever
unune tuile pour Monsieur Duhai.
PaParce que la population au
QuQuébec elle est favorable à
l'l'avortement. Ce sont les
prprovinces qui sont responsabls
dede donner l'accès à l'avortemt
etet au Québec, il y a un accès.
ReRelativement bon. Mais on sait
quque c'est fragile. On voit que
d'd'autres provinces ne donnent
papas le même accès. Ça demeure
unune embûche pour Monsieur
DuDuhaime.
- - Cette variation dans les
acaccès, ça fait en sorte Monsir
TrTrudeau sera peut-être tenté e
titirer sur certaines selles. En
plplus il a l'occasion de voulor
totorpiller les adversaires
coconservateurs.
- - À propos des accès, ça a plé
JuJustin Trudeau quand même un u
susur la sellette cette semaine.
C'C'était une promesse électorae
dudu Parti libéral de se servire
lala loi canadienne sur la santé
popour améliorer l'accès à
l'l'avortement au pays. C'était
lolors des dernières élections t
ririen n'a été fait depuis à ce
chchapitre la. L'opposition nos
dédémocrates à 10: c'est bien bu
dede parler de l'avortement mais
fafait en sorte que l'accès soit
amamélioré. Le droit il existe s
ccôtés de l'accès qu'il y a un
prproblème. Ça a placé Justin
TrTrudeau dans une position
vuvulnérable. Il a évoqué la
popossibilité de légiférer ça
auaussi, ça a suscité certaines
crcraintes. Entre autres du Bloc
ququébécois disant mieux vaut ne
papas nécessairement ouvrir cete
boboîte de pandore, parce que si
onon légifère, il y a une
popossibilité de pente savonneu.
SiSi on légifère, s'il y a loi
c'c'est plus facile après de
l'l'amender, de la changer. Ça
popourrait entraîner des
rerestrictions à l'avortement P.
CÇa c'est pour la semaine un peu
plplus compliquée de Justin
TrTrudeau. Mais c'est vrai que
sysystématiquement, lorsqu'il et
ququestion d'avortement il veut
pepeser sur ce bouton là. Parce
ququ'il sait que les conservates
sosont vulnérables. On le disait
totout à l'heure. À peu près le
titiers du caucus est contre
l'l'avortement. C'est un caucus
ququi est divisé sur cette
ququestion. Alors que la
popopulation canadienne pas
seseulement québécoise, est
mamajoritairement favorable à
l'l'avortement. Probablement que
c'c'est encore plus fort au
QuQuébec. Au pays en général, la
popopulation canadienne est
gégénéralement pour le fait qu'n
coconserve ce droit.
- - Une petite minute pour parlr
dede ce 10e départ annoncé au sn
dudu parti libéral du Québec Pal
RoRobitaille.
- - C'est différent des neuf
auautres, elle est là depuis
seseulement un mandat. Elle
s's'était marquée depuis la
papandémie. Le quartier pendanta
papandémie a été touché. C'est
ététonnant. Visiblement il y a
ququelque chose qui marchait pas
avavec Dominique Anglade. Quand
elelle a commencé elle avait des
bebeaux dossiers en relation
ininternationale qui est dans ss
cocordes ou la lutte contre la
papauvreté mais depuis septembr,
elelle est en charge de
l'l'agriculture, honnêtement on
n'n'est pas loin de la tablette.
OnOn peut comprendre qu'elle a
vovoulu partir.
- - Merci beaucoup Madelei